d'accord
[Musique]
nous avons trouvé beaucoup de
plastiques à usage unique, disons de l'aluminium
et du verre, des bouteilles en verre des canettes en aluminium
beaucoup de choses que vous trouvez dans votre cuisine
[Musique étrangère]
image que nous avons rencontrée partout dans
les îles grecques  ce qui signifie que nous pouvons
totalement voir l'impact de la
société locale les pêcheurs locaux mais ensuite nous
avons l'impact du euh le tourisme
vous savez les yachts C'est généralement le
même mélange de déchets marins
[Musique]
étranger
placez-les dehors  pendant quelques jours afin que les
gens soient plus sensibles aux
dommages qui peuvent survenir
[Musique]
étranger